wake up your sweet tooth with the
chocolate for breakfast bar set that's
bacon luscious and write down your to-do
list on this piggy bank made out of
post-it notes because it's episode 49 of
loose carry SunPower on your back with
the voltaic solar backpack that features
a solar panel and battery designed to
transfer a few hours in the Sun into a
fully charged smartphone and the fabric
is made of recycled soda bottles with
waterproof backing to protect your
devices devise some beats from your
pants using a pocket drum machine
Teenage Engineering's pocket operators
series features the battery-operated
drum machine bass synthesizer and a lead
synthesizer they each have 16 different
sounds and effects to make stuff on the
go like this monitor the circadian
rhythm of your newborn thanks to the
MIMO smart baby monitor a machine
washable onesie that tracks breathing
body position and sleep status and sends
the data to your smartphone so you can
finally get a good night's sleep on your
ostrich arm pillow the Valentine's Day
mystery box is filled with I don't know
and neither will she or he or Cthulhu
plush unicorn bouquet that replaces
roses with a magical gift of unicorns
each on their own stem that's detachable
attach these overly complicated wooden
light switches that use gears
rack-and-pinion toggles and levers that
are installed over existing plastic
covers cover yourself and some friends
with the world's largest Underpants and
have the world's most famous lake
monster stick its head out of pans when
using the Nessie ladle ha ha ha ha roll
the tape on your pets in the cuddliest
way possible by ordering a customized
plush replica from cuddle clones calm
just upload some pictures of your
four-legged companion and in a few
months you'll have your own stuffed
dragon around ice-cold beverages is easy
with the ice mule a portable cooler that
keeps contents cold for up to 24 hours
and can be easily rolled up and stored
when not in
use use key Kong to hold on to your keys
so you always know where they are and
all key Kong asks for in return is just
don't take me for granted the text blade
doesn't take touch-typing for granted at
just one-third the size and weight of an
iPhone it provides the same full finger
spacing of a desktop and sets itself up
magnetically and the battery lasts about
a month per charge get medieval in your
writing after having a pen bestowed by a
bowing knight or bring knight into the
future with the Leo smart alert
nightlight not only can you set its
brightness and color it has an ambient
light setting to turn on when the lights
get low it also listens for smoke alarm
and carbon monoxide alarms and monitors
temperature and humidity and then alerts
your smartphone if anything is amiss
feel free to miss your mouth when
wearing a hydrophobic t-shirt from
thread Smith's the 100% cotton shirts
contain no chemicals and are crafted
with a patented hydrophobic
nanotechnology that repels water and
dirt and serum and as always thanks for
watching